But go ahead. Yeah.
Well, uh, two weeks ago, uh, me and the
friend who introduced me to this priest,
we went to the, we went out to have a
picnic. So, he actually recently he
divorc his wife and um I don't want to
go to the very detail. Yeah.
Uh, he divorced. I just asked him why
divorce. You say we had some
disagreement and some kind of you know
with my wife and we couldn't get along
with each other. Oh wow. The the the
weird thing happened the the the priest
name I don't want to mention his name
his the priest told him to divorce his
wife.
It's very very weird to me why because
he's a corrupt priest. He's a corrupt
priest. You have people in churches
where the leadership they're not true
leaders. They are wolves in sheep's
clothing, sons of the devil, and to them
it's just a job. So that priest who
would tell someone to divorce his wife
for no biblical reason, he is not a true
priest. He's an agent of the devil and
it's just a job for him.
So obviously when as soon as I I
realized this he told me what happened
with the priest because I know this is
against uh Jesus teaching isn't it? Of
course it's against Jesus's teaching.
Yeah. Uh and then I tried to stop to go
to this church. You know I just want to
take your opinion. My opinion is if a
priest condones a person sinning against
God and divorcing his spouse for no
biblical reason, that priest is a tool
of the devil. Go find you a solid church
with a solid priest.
He he said one of the friend told me me
and wife we couldn't get along with each
other. We had wife but in my opinion the
priest shouldn't actually advise him to
do that. Brother, where did Jesus say
that if you and your wife don't get
along, you can leave each other?
I I I I never heard that. That's not in
the Bible. So, if a priest doesn't even
know that much about the Bible, he's a
tool of the devil. Leave that church. Go
find you a solid church with solid
priests.
Yeah. Yeah. That's what I'm going to do
actually because I'm I'm trying very
very hard to practice the Christianity.
You know, I'm ex-Muslim. So I I have a
full faith in Jesus Christ. So just want
to find a a right way to Hallelujah.
Jesus Christ our Lord increase your
faith and love for him and protect you.
Write down and read it when you have a
chance. Matthew 5 27 and 28. Write these
down. You ready?
Okay. Just a second. Sorry. So you can
read them on your own leisure and we'll
talk about them later. And then that's
that's my advice to you.
Matthew 5. It's up to you. But huh.
Let me just get a pen and paper. Okay.
Yeah, I'm ready. So, what's that? You
want to write down Matthew 5 27-28.
25 28 Matthew 5. Matthew chapter 5 27-
28. Matthew
Matthew 5 verses 27 to 28.
28. And then Matthew 5, same chapter
31-32.
3132.
Matthew 19. Chapter 19.
Sorry. Matthew what? Chapter 19. Chapter
19. Verses 1-9.
[Music]
1 to 9. And then 1 Corinthians 7:es 10
to 11.
10 to 11. And then
then then you read then you read Acts 20
27-32. Acts 20 27-32. Okay.
[Music]
27-22
to 32. 27 32. You can't go 27 to 22.
Acts 20 27 to 32. Right. 32. Yeah. Of
course. Okay.
Now, why am I giving you those verses?
Because in Acts 20
27:32, Paul warns Christians, there'll
be wolves, wolves pretending to be
Christians to destroy Christians.
And then Jesus and Paul say if a man or
a woman leave their spouse other than
for zindah zna sexual immorality and
they marry someone else, they are
committing zindah adultery because Paul
says two
believers, two believers who are
married cannot divorce but if they
separate
They remain
separate or they try to get back
together but you don't have an option of
divorcing and remarrying. He says the
Lord says except for sexual immorality
zah and I'll talk about that in a
session where I'm going to respond to
objections by people who say Christians
have no grounds to remarry for whatever
reason which they're wrong. But anyway,
you get the point. The priest say
divorce your wife and she hasn't
committed
zna sexual
immorality. That priest is garbage. He's
of the
devil. Okay. He's a wolf. He's a wolf.
He's garbage.
Well, that's what I thought actually. I
mean since I hear that I just like it's
been it's like reflecting in my mind all
the time what kind of praise is it mean
I is against Christianity against
Christianity it's against Christianity
but now you ask the Holy Spirit to guide
you to a church with priests who fear
God leave it don't go back tell your
friend you're in sin you're disgracing
Jesus I don't accept your decision to
divorce your life. I condemn you if you
don't change your mind because you're
going against Jesus and shame on you
that I someone who used who used to be a
Muslim who's now a Christian is having
to teach you your
faith. Okay.
Yeah. Especially marriage in
Christianity is very I mean I can't very
hard much in this. Yeah. You got all
those verses. When you read them, call
me back later. We'll talk more about
them. But read them for now and we'll
talk more in the future. God willing.
Okay. Thank you so much. Thank you very
much for your time, sir. Anytime. God
guide you and protect you, brother.
Thank you so much, my brother. Thank
you. Have a good day. Sorry. In here is
9:10. Amen. God bless. Okay. God bless
you.
Pray for Ali. Former Muslims now a
Christian who loves Jesus